nous pouvons chercher ces signaux dans le sang
afin de dépister ces cancers au plus tôt.
Au lieu d'attendre que les cancers soient assez grands pour causer des symptômes,
ou assez denses pour être visible sur l'imagerie,
ou assez visibles
pour qu'ils puissent être vus lors de procédures médicales,
nous pouvons commencer à chercher les cancers encore relativement petits,
en cherchant ces petites quantités d'ADN dans le sang.
Laissez-moi expliquer comment on fait.
Premièrement, nous commençons avec une simple prise de sang --
pas de radiation, pas d'équipement compliqué --
une simple prise de sang.
Ensuite, le sang nous est envoyé,
et nous extrayons l'ADN de ce test sanguin.
Alors que le corps est composé de cellules en bonne santé,
la plupart de l'ADN détecté proviendra de cellules en bonne santé.
Il y aura quand-même une petite partie, moins d'1%,
qui proviendra des cellules cancéreuses.
Ensuite on utilise des méthodes de biologie moléculaire
afin d'enrichir cet ADN
pour les endroits du génome qui sont connus pour être associées au cancer,
selon les informations des projets des génomes du cancer.
Ensuite, nous mettons cet ADN dans les machines de séquençage
et nous pouvons numériser l'ADN en A, C, T et G
afin d'avoir la lecture finale.
Pour finir, nous avons des information de milliards de lettres
qui ressortent de cette série.
Ensuit, nous appliquons des méthodes statistiques et informatiques
afin de trouver le petit signal présent,
qui indique une petite quantité d'ADN du cancer dans le sang.
Alors, est-ce que ça fonctionne réellement avec des patients ?
Eh bien, comme il n'est vraiment possible de prévoir maintenant
quels patients attraperont le cancer,
nous utilisons ceux qui s'en rapprochent le plus :
les cancers en remission ;
et plus spécifiquement, le cancer du poumon.
Malheureusement, même avec les meilleurs médicaments d'aujourd'hui,
la plupart des cancers du poumon reviennent.
L'élément important est de voir
si nous sommes capables de dépister ces cancers récurrents
plus tôt qu'avec des méthodes standard.
Nous venons de terminer un essai majeur
avec le professeur Charles Swanton à l'University College de Londres,
à ce sujet.
Laissez-moi vous montrer un exemple avec un patient.
C'est l'exemple d'un patient qui recourt à la chirurgie
à un moment donné,
et doit ensuite recourir à la chimiothérapie.
Ensuite, le patient se trouve en rémission.
Il est surveillé à l'aide d'examens cliniques et de l'imagerie médicale.
Autour du 450ème jour, malheureusement, le cancer revient.
La question est : est-on capables de le dépister avant ?
Pendant tout ce temps, nous avons collecté continuellement du sang
afin de mesurer la quantité de ADNct dans le sang.
Donc, au point de départ, comme prévu,
il y a un grand niveau d'ADN cancéreux dans le sang.
Cependant, il disparaît ensuite
et reste négligeable après plusieurs mesures .
Cependant, autour du 340ème jour,
nous voyons la montée de l'ADN cancéreux dans le sang,
et pour finir, il remonte entre le 400 et le 450ème jour.
Voilà la clé de l'histoire, si vous l'avez manquée :
au 340ème jour, nous voyons la montée de l'ADN cancéreux dans le sang.
Cela signifie qu'on dépiste ce cancer plus d'une centaine de jours
avant les méthodes traditionnelles.
C'est cent jours plus tôt, où l'on peut donner des médicaments,
cent jours plut tôt, où l'on peut faire de la chirurgie,
ou même cent jours de moins, où le cancer ne grandit pas
ou cent jours de moins, où la résistance se produit.
Pour certains patients, ces cent jours sont une question de vie ou de mort.
Nous sommes vraiment heureux de cette information.
Grâce à tout cela, nous avons fait des recherches additionnelles
sur d'autres cancers,
y compris le cancer du sein, du poumon
et des ovaires,
et je suis impatient de voir
avec combien d'avance nous dépisterons ces cancers
Pour finir, j'ai un rêve,
un rêve de deux fioles de sang,
et qu'un jour, dans le futur, dans tous nos examens médicaux standard,
on nous prendra deux fioles de sang.
Et à partir de ces deux fioles de sang, nous pourrons comparer
l'ADN de toutes les signatures des cancers,
et dépister les cancers des mois, voire des années plus tôt.
Même avec les thérapies que nous avons actuellement,
cela signifie que des millions de vies pourraient être sauvées.
Si vous ajouter à cela les récentes avancées en immunothérapie,
et en thérapies ciblées,
la fin du cancer est proche.
La prochaine fois que vous entendrez le mot « cancer »,
j'aimerais que vous ajoutiez le mot : espoir.
Ayez confiance.
Les oncologues du monde entier travaillent avec ferveur
afin de battre cette maladie,
et des progrès incroyables sont en cours.
C'est le début de la fin.
Nous gagnerons la guerre contre le cancer.
Et pour moi, c'est une nouvelle incroyable.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)